This is one of those stories where something big and heartwarming and idealistic that somebody wants is just going to get torn apart. Just driven straight into the ground. And it begins, as these kind of stories often do, with an idea that was planted in somebody's head when they were a child.
这是一个关于某个宏大、感人且理想主义的愿望最终分崩离析的故事。它被彻底碾碎了。正如这类故事通常那样，它始于某人在童年时期被植入脑海的一个想法。
Back when she was a little girl, Erin Einhorn was told this family legend, and, as some legends go, it was kind of a spectacular one. When Erin was a girl, she used to beg her mom to talk about it.
艾琳·艾因霍恩（Erin Einhorn）小时候听过一个家族传奇，像许多传说一样，它相当壮观。艾琳小时候总缠着妈妈讲这个故事。
I love the story. Because I, of course, was born in suburban Detroit, where my life was really boring. And she had this really dramatic story, of this incredible survival.
我喜欢这个故事。因为我当然是出生在底特律郊区，那里的生活非常乏味。而她有这样一个关于非凡生存的戏剧性故事。
The story went like this. Erin's grandfather and grandmother were on their way to work one morning in Poland, and were rounded up by the Nazis, and they're put on the train to Auschwitz. So they are on this train.
故事是这样的：艾琳的爷爷奶奶在波兰的一个早晨去上班，被纳粹围捕，并被送往奥斯威辛集中营的火车上。所以，他们就在这列火车上。
So my grandfather sees a way to escape from this train, like an open window. And he turns to his wife, Sura Leah Rosenblum, and he pleads with her to jump with him from the train. My grandmother's about 21, 22 years old and she's just terrified. And she refuses to go.
我爷爷看到了一条逃离火车的路，比如一扇开着的窗户。他转向妻子苏拉·莉亚·罗森布鲁姆（Sura Leah Rosenblum），恳求她和他一起跳下去。我奶奶当时大约21、22岁，她吓坏了，拒绝跳车。
To jump from the moving train. The train is moving?
从行驶的火车上跳下去。火车在行驶吗？
It's at moving train. And the story is that it's a window. I'm not sure what that means, if there was a window, why other people didn't jump. If you apply some questions to the story, it doesn't necessarily hold up. But I never did apply questions to the story particularly. Because it was this incredible story.
那是行驶中的火车。故事里提到那是扇窗户。我不确定这意味着什么，如果有扇窗户，为什么其他人不跳？如果你对这个故事提出质疑，它未必站得住脚。但我从未刻意去质疑它，因为它是个了不起的故事。
So there's a train, and there's a window. And my grandfather wants to jump. And he wants his wife to come with him, and she refuses. And he goes by himself. And he leaps from the train, as the story goes, in a hail of bullets from the Nazi guards. And he is wounded in the leg. He's bleeding from the leg.
所以有一列火车，有一扇窗户。我爷爷想跳。他想让妻子跟他一起走，但她拒绝了。他独自一人行动。据故事所说，他在纳粹警卫密集的枪林弹雨中从火车上跳下。他的腿受伤了，流着血。
So the history goes like this. He takes the yellow armband with the Star of David that the Nazis made all the Jews wear. This is pretty much a symbol of everything that had gone wrong for his people. And he removes it from his arm, and he wraps it around his leg, as a bandage. And then he runs back to his town, Bedzin, to find his daughter. Who is Erin's mother, who was then just a baby. Who they had left with an elderly relative before they went off to work in the morning.
历史是这样记录的：他取下纳粹强制所有犹太人佩戴的带有大卫星的黄色袖标。这基本上象征着对他族人而言一切错误的根源。他从胳膊上取下袖标，缠在腿上当作绷带。然后他跑回他的家乡本津（Bedzin）去寻找女儿，也就是艾琳的母亲。当时她还是个婴儿，那天早上他们去上班前把她留给了一位年长的亲戚。
Then he goes with her to the home of a woman he knew. And the woman's name is Honorata Skowronski. And he begs her to take care of his child, and he promises her all kinds of things, and riches and he'll take care of her for the rest of his life. And he asks her if she'll hide my mother among her other children. She had a number of children. And she agreed.
然后，他带着她去了他认识的一位女人的家里，那个女人的名字叫奥诺拉塔·斯科隆斯卡（Honorata Skowronski）。他恳求她照顾他的孩子，许诺给她各种东西，许诺给予财富，并保证余生都会照顾她。他问她是否愿意将我母亲藏在她的其他孩子中间——她有几个孩子。她同意了。
And then he's ultimately captured again. And ends up back at Auschwitz and then Buchenwald. And he comes back after the war, and somehow is able to find my mother again. I mean, his wife is gone. His parents are gone. His brothers are gone. His sister's gone. Their spouses, their children, his cousins, his friends, everybody. But the one person, the one thing, really, he still has from that life is this child, my mother.
后来他最终还是再次被捕，并被送回了奥斯威辛，后来又到了布痕瓦尔德集中营。战后他回来了，不知怎么地又找到了我母亲。我的意思是，他的妻子不在了，父母不在了，兄弟不在了，姐妹也不在了。他们的配偶、孩子、表亲、朋友，所有人都没了。但他从那段生活中幸存下来的唯一的人，实际上也就是唯一的依靠，就是这个孩子，我的母亲。
Because of this woman, this hero, who risked her life. Poland actually had the death penalty for saving a Jew.
多亏了这个女人，这个冒着生命危险的英雄。在波兰，救助犹太人是要判死刑的。
Now one confusing thing about this incredible story, as far as Erin was concerned, was the fact that nobody in her family liked to talk about it. Nobody saw this woman as a hero.
关于这个了不起的故事，对艾琳来说有一件令人困惑的事，就是家里没人愿意谈论它。没有人把这个女人视为英雄。
I mean, my mother was really flip about the whole thing. She would say, "Well, she only did it for the money," or something. Which I didn't particularly believe. The truth is, we didn't really discuss any of this. My mother just hated to talk about it. The whole story really bored her. I think she just didn't-- she came to the United States at the age of nine, as this kind of big-nosed, red-haired Jewish girl who spoke Swedish. Because they had actually lived in Sweden after the war for four years.
我母亲对此总是轻描淡写。她会说：“噢，她只是为了钱才这么做的，”之类的话。我并不怎么相信。事实是，我们并没有真正讨论过这些。我母亲非常讨厌谈论这件事。整个故事让她觉得很无聊。我想她只是……她在9岁那年来到美国，是个长着大鼻子、红头发、说着瑞典语的犹太女孩。因为战后他们在瑞典住了四年。
So she was this really, really odd kid, and she really didn't fit in. And I think she just wanted the whole thing behind her.
所以她是个非常、非常奇怪的孩子，真的很难融入。我想她只是想把这一切抛在脑后。
Yeah.
是的。
But I mean, to me, it was this important-- it was a story that I would tell that I thought kind of made my mother special, you know. There was this woman, out there, or her family anyway, there was this part, this important part of my mother's story.
但对我来说，这是一个重要的……这是一个我会讲述的故事，我认为它让我的母亲变得与众不同，你知道。那个女人在那儿，或者至少她的家人在那儿，这是我母亲故事中重要的一部分。
And I actually really wanted to connect my mother with that part of her past. Even though she wasn't really particularly interested in it. I wanted to see what would happen. Or just thought, maybe if I could find this family my mother would show an interest, she would be moved by it in some way.
我其实非常想让我的母亲与她过去的那部分重新建立联系。尽管她并不是特别感兴趣。我想看看会发生什么。或者我只是想，也许如果我能找到这家人，我母亲会表现出兴趣，她会被某种方式触动。
So Erin moved to Poland for a year to figure this out. To have an adventure. She's 27. And what she finds is so much more complicated than what she expected. And so different than what she expected.
于是艾琳在波兰住了一年，试图弄清这件事，寻求一场冒险。她当时27岁。她所发现的一切比她预想的复杂得多，也完全不同。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, "Settling the Score." Our program today in two acts. And the two stories in our show today have so much in common, but actually, saying what they have in common right now, actually telling you what are the things they have in common is going to spoil what is going to happen in the stories, as they unfold.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台制作的《美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天我们节目的主题是“了结夙愿”。今天的节目分两部分。我们节目中的两个故事有很多共同点，但现在说出它们的共同点会剧透故事的发展。
So, for now, I'm just going to say that in both stories there are people, there are these this mysterious, unfolding conflicts where it's not even clear for a while, for a long while, what the conflicts are about. And there are other similarities to them, key similarities, yet to be revealed. Stay with us.
所以，目前我只想说，在这两个故事中，人们都在经历一些神秘的、不断展开的冲突，在很长一段时间里，甚至不清楚冲突究竟是什么。它们还有其他关键的相似之处，暂不揭晓。请继续收听。
Act One, "One Good Deed." So Erin Einhorn, the woman with the amazing family legend that nobody in her family likes to talk about, she heads off to Poland.
第一部分，“一件善事”。艾琳·艾因霍恩，那个拥有一个家人都不愿谈论的神奇家族传说的女人，启程前往波兰。
And basically what she has in her hand is an address. Of this building that her grandfather owned before the war in Bedzin. She knows that after the war, one thing that her grandfather did to thank the woman who saved her mother's life, Honorata Skowronski, is that he told her to move in there, into this building, rent free.
她手里基本上只有一个地址。那是她爷爷战前在本津拥有的那栋房子的地址。她知道战后，爷爷为了感谢救过她母亲生命的奥诺拉塔·斯科隆斯卡，曾告诉她搬进那栋楼里住，免收房租。
Erin figured that Honorata was probably dead, it was so long ago. But that somebody there might remember Honorata's family, have some idea of where the people had gone to.
艾琳以为奥诺拉塔可能已经去世了，毕竟过去太久了。但她想那里或许有人记得奥诺拉塔的家人，知道他们搬到了哪里。
So Erin's living in Poland, she's learning some Polish. And one day she takes some friends with her, partly to help with the translation, to the town of Bedzin, to try to find this address. And when she gets there, she's completely surprised. First of all, she had sort of pictured the town like it would be the town in Fiddler on the Roof , with cows and goats and thatched roofs and all. A village, basically.
艾琳住在波兰，正在学习一些波兰语。有一天，她带着几个朋友去本津，一部分是为了帮忙翻译，试着找那个地址。当她到达那里时，她完全惊呆了。首先，她原本想象的小镇就像《屋顶上的小提琴手》里的样子，有牛、有羊、有茅草屋顶。基本上就是一个村庄。
But, in fact, the building is in a real city. On a street with shoe stores and a sidewalk cafe. And it turns out to be a three story building, like a townhouse, broken up into five or six apartments. With iron balconies.
但实际上，那栋楼在一座真正的城市里。街道上有鞋店和人行道咖啡馆。它是一栋三层楼的建筑，就像联排别墅，分成了五六套公寓。带有铁艺阳台。
But it's really rundown. Actually, one of the balconies is kind of twisted and almost falling off. We go in and the stairs are cracked, there are marble stairs that are cracked and there's actually graffiti on the wall. It smells bad. It's a little squalid.
但它非常破旧。事实上，其中一个阳台已经扭曲，几乎要掉下来了。我们走进去，楼梯上有裂缝，那是大理石楼梯，墙上还有涂鸦。闻起来很难闻，有点肮脏。
Yeah.
是的。
So we went up the first set of stairs on the left, and knocked on the first door. And we had this name Skowronski. And so one of my friends asked this woman who answered the door, "Is Skowronski here?" or something. And the woman-- from my perspective, I can't really speak Polish. But I see the woman nod and point toward the sky. And I'm like, oh, they're dead.
我们上了左边的第一层楼梯，敲了第一扇门。我们有“斯科隆斯卡”这个名字。我的一位朋友问开门的那位女士：“斯科隆斯卡在这里吗？”或者类似的话。那位女士——从我的角度看，我不懂波兰语。但我看到她点点头，指了指天空。我心想，噢，他们死了。
And my friend laughs and he's like, "No, they live upstairs." So all of a sudden now, we're like, oh my god, they're here. And actually, I mean, various things happen, but essentially the next thing I know I'm standing face to face with this old man, with tired blue eyes, who once called my mother his sister.
我朋友笑了，他说：“不，他们住在楼上。”所以突然之间，我们想，天哪，他们在这里。事实上，发生了各种各样的事情，但基本上接下来我发现自己面对面站着的是一个有着疲惫蓝眼睛的老人，他曾经称呼我母亲为妹妹。
And I had this photograph that my mother had given me, right before I went to Poland. It was my mother at about maybe four or five years old. Just this little kid, and she looked like she had been crying maybe. Her eyes were kind of puffy. And her father's in this picture with her, looking very serious.
我有一张我母亲去波兰前给我的照片。那是我母亲大约四五岁的时候。只是个小孩子，看起来好像哭过。她的眼睛有点浮肿。她父亲在这张照片里和她在一起，表情非常严肃。
And then there's this woman, this stern looking woman. And my mother never really knew who this woman was, actually. She thought it might have been Honorata Skowronski. She wasn't entirely sure. But I had this picture.
旁边还有个女人，一个看起来很严厉的女人。其实我母亲从不知道那个女人是谁。她以为可能是奥诺拉塔·斯科隆斯卡。她不太确定。但我有这张照片。
And I handed it to this guy, and he just starts. He stares at the picture. He says, [SPEAKING POLISH]. "That's my mother." And I pointed at the child in the photo and I said, [SPEAKING POLISH]. "That's my mother."
我把它交给那个男人，他盯着照片开始（说波兰语）。“那是我母亲。”我指着照片里的孩子说（说波兰语）。“那是我母亲。”
And the guy just started to cry. I mean, tears running down his face and he just took me in his arms and he says, "She was my sister." He invites us in and he just starts telling us this story about-- she used to follow him around. He was her favorite. He used to change her diapers. He used to make her pancakes. He used to milk the goat so that she would have fresh milk. And when the guards would-- or the SS would march in the street, or the Gestapo-- he would hide her in a dresser drawer. Because she was just this child.
那个人开始哭起来。眼泪顺着他的脸流下来，他紧紧拥抱着我，说：“她是我的妹妹。”他邀请我们进去，开始讲起故事——她过去常跟着他。她是他的最爱。他会帮她换尿布，给她做煎饼。他会挤羊奶，好让她能喝上新鲜的牛奶。当卫兵——或者党卫军、盖世太保在街上行军时——他会把她藏在梳妆台的抽屉里，因为她还是个孩子。
And then one day, she basically vanished. I mean, her father comes for her at the end of the war. And he never, ever sees her again. She lived there for three years. They were really close.
然后有一天，她基本上消失了。战争结束时，她父亲来接她。之后他再也没见过她。她在那儿住了三年，他们非常亲密。
And, in a way, this is exactly what you had pictured might happen, right? If everything would go wonderfully.
在某种程度上，这正是你所设想可能会发生的事情，对吧？如果一切都进展得非常完美的话。
Yeah, it was like a dream come true. You know, it was one of those moments where everything is just resolved and everything's perfect. It was more than-- and he's just, "You have to bring your mother to me. I really, I want to see her before I die. You'll bring her." His mother, it turns out, had been passed away in 1995.
是的，就像梦想成真。你知道，那是一个一切问题都得到解决、一切都很完美的时刻。远不止于此——他只是说，“你必须把你母亲带到我这里。我真的想在她去世前见她一面。你会带她来的。”顺便一提，他的母亲在1995年已经去世了。
But he says, "Bring your mother. We'll take her to my mother's grave, and she'll know that her daughter had come back." He used the word daughter. I mean, it was all kind of a shock.
但他坚持说：“带你母亲来。我们会带她去我母亲的坟前，她就会知道她的女儿回来了。”他用了“女儿”这个词。这一切让我感到非常震惊。
We got his phone number, and I said, "Look, you know, can I come back? And we can sit down and talk." And he said, "Sure, no problem." And we made arrangements to meet again in a couple of weeks.
我们留了他的电话，我说：“看，我可以再来吗？我们可以坐下来谈谈。”他说：“当然，没问题。”我们约定几周后再见。
When she goes back, it's a big deal. The man's whole family is there. His wife, a bunch of grown kids and grandkids. They serve cake and coffee. Erin's roommate Manda comes, to help translate.
当她再次回去时，这是一件大事。那个人的全家人都在场。他的妻子，还有一堆成年的孩子和孙辈。他们准备了蛋糕和咖啡。艾琳的室友曼达（Manda）也来了，帮忙翻译。
And so actually, that next meeting was actually really just wonderful. Just to get all these stories and just hear what they'd heard. Their half of this story that I'd heard. But it turns out that, actually, as much as I was excited about going back and finding this family, it turns out that they had really been excited about the possibility that I was coming back.
那次见面其实非常美妙。能收集到所有的故事，听到他们所知道的部分，听到我所听到的故事的另一面。但事实证明，尽管我对于重返并找到这家人感到兴奋，但他们似乎对我可能会回来这件事也非常激动。
Because it turned out there was this whole back story that I hadn't anticipated having to do with this house that had been my family's property. My translator-- actually Honorata's son is named Wieslaw Skowronski. So I really want to talk to him, and hear what he remembers. But his wife and his daughter start talking to my translator. I'm mean, just really, really rapidly. I am begging her to translate.
因为这背后有一个我没预料到的故事，关于那栋曾经属于我家族房产的房子。我的翻译——实际上奥诺拉塔的儿子叫维斯瓦夫·斯科隆斯卡（Wieslaw Skowronski）。所以我非常想和他谈谈，听听他的回忆。但他的妻子和女儿开始和我翻译用极快的语速交谈。我求她翻译。
We're actually arguing. I'm like, "Manda, translate!" And she says "It's hard! It's complicated!" And every time she tried to stop them, they would just keep going. And increasingly adamant. Just over and over and over again. And I would say, "What's going on?" And she said, "Well, it has to do with the house. I think that they want your mother to sign some document?"
我们其实在争论。我喊道：“曼达，翻译一下！”她说：“这很难！太复杂了！”每次她想打断她们，她们就会继续说下去，而且越来越坚定，一遍又一遍。我问：“发生什么事了？”她说：“好吧，这和房子有关。我想她们想让你母亲签份文件？”
This pretty much, right here, is where Erin's entire dream is going to play out like some heartwarming A&E special, this is where that dream starts to fall apart. And in this second meeting, Erin can't even the story straight of what family wants, and what's gone wrong with the house that they need fixed. And what they are even talking about. All she can tell, from the urgency of their voices and their expressions, is that it is really, really important to them.
就在这里，艾琳原本那个像温馨电视专题片一样的梦，开始破灭了。在第二次会面中，艾琳甚至搞不清楚这家人到底想要什么，房子出了什么问题需要解决，他们在谈论什么。她只能从他们说话的紧迫感和表情中感觉到，这对他们来说真的、真的非常重要。
It takes several more meetings, over the course of months, to get the whole thing straight.
又过了几个月，进行了好几次会议，才把整件事弄清楚。
Well, it turns out that my grandfather had to given Honorata Skowronski permission to live in his house, as the manager, but not to sell the place basically. It was the only right she didn't have. And she had the power to collect the rent from tenants. There were, I think, eight or 10 apartment buildings. And she could collect the rent from the tenants. She had to pay the taxes. And she could keep whatever was leftover.
原来，我爷爷曾许可奥诺拉塔·斯科隆斯卡住在他的房子里担任管理员，但没有卖掉房子的权限。这是她唯一没有的权利。她有权向租户收取租金。当时那里有八或十栋公寓楼。她可以向租户收租，但必须交税，剩下的归她所有。
And that arrangement worked perfectly fine until 1995, when Honorata Skowronski died. And then the tenants stopped paying. They said, you are not the owner, we don't have to pay you. And so they went, her son and his wife, went to the municipality for support. And said, you know, help us force these renters to pay. And the town said, well, let me see the deed, and they look at the deed. And there's this name, Friedrich, on the deed.
这种安排运行得非常完美，直到1995年奥诺拉塔去世。然后租户停止付钱了。他们说，你不是房东，我们没必要付给你。于是她儿子和儿媳就去市政厅寻求支持，要求市政厅帮忙强制租户交租。镇政府说，好吧，让我看看产权证明，他们一看产权证明，上面写着“弗里德里希”（Friedrich）这个名字。
And they're like, who's Friedrich? And they're like, well, you know, there was this Jew and he had a daughter and we saved the daughter. But it fly. And so, meanwhile, they still have to pay the taxes. They have to pay the taxes, they have to pay the utility bills. But they can't collect rent from the tenants. The tenants are living there for free.
他们问：谁是弗里德里希？对方回答：噢，有个犹太人，他有个女儿，我们救了这个女儿。但这行不通。同时，他们还得继续缴税。他们必须支付税款，支付水电费，却不能从租户那里收租金。租户们实际上是免费住在那里的。
Do you volunteer to basically get your mom to sign a paper for them? What do you do?
你是否主动提出让你母亲为他们签那份文件？你打算怎么做？
I was like, yeah, sure. Yeah. I'll look into it. Later on I would actually discover that it's, frankly, not anywhere close to as simple as they though that it was.
我说：好吧，当然。我会研究一下。后来我发现，坦白说，这远没有他们想象的那么简单。
In fact, the lengths that Erin has to go through to clear up this bit of business for them are breathtaking, even by the standards of nations that used to be behind the Iron Curtain. We're going to dwell here on them at some length, because for any of us who have actually been caught up in some months long bureaucratic run around with an HMO, or the phone company, or our own federal government, it is heartening to know that there are still places in the world that make these kinds of problems with American bureaucracy seem minuscule.
事实上，艾琳为帮他们处理这件琐事所经历的重重困难，即使以那些曾经身处铁幕后的国家标准来看，也是惊人的。我们要详细讲讲这些，因为对于我们中那些曾经陷入过医疗保险机构、电话公司或联邦政府长达数月官僚主义纠缠的人来说，得知世界上还有些地方能让美国的官僚主义问题显得微不足道，确实令人感到欣慰。
Yes, no matter how badly we can botch things up here in America sometimes, and God knows we can do it pretty badly sometimes, we can always console ourselves with the thought that things can be much worse. There is still, in this world, a special standard of bureaucratic horribleness known everywhere by the phrase "Former Soviet ally."
是的，无论我们在美国有时能把事情搞得有多糟——上帝知道我们有时确实做得够烂——我们总能用“事情可能更糟”来安慰自己。在这个世界上，仍然有一种被称为“前苏联盟友”的特殊官僚主义恐怖标准。
So I went to the Consulate and I asked for advice. And they said, well, actually we don't give out advice. They give you lists of lawyers who speak English. So I went to a lawyer, and actually his advice was very complicated, so I went to another lawyer. And then that lawyer had completely different advice. So I went to a third lawyer, and, in any event, they all basically agree on one thing. And that is that, in fact, my mother couldn't sign anything, and I couldn't sign anything, and even if my grandfather were alive, he couldn't sign anything because, in fact, none of us own the property.
所以我去了领事馆咨询建议。他们说，噢，其实我们不提供建议。他们只给你一份会说英语的律师名单。所以我找了一个律师，他的建议非常复杂，所以我又找了另一个。那个律师的建议则完全不同。于是我又找了第三个律师。总之，他们一致同意一件事：其实我母亲没法签任何东西，我也不能签，甚至如果我爷爷还活着，他也不能签，因为事实上我们谁也不拥有这个房产。
The property is owned by Israel and Zizsla Friedrich, who are my great grandparents. And so what I needed to do before I could do anything at all to help the Skowronski's with their property problem, was to inherit the house from my great grandparents. But the first hurdle for that is before you can even begin an inheritance procedure, you have to file a death certificate with a register of wills. But I didn't have a death certificate, because they died in the Holocaust.
房产所有者是我曾祖父母以色列和齐斯拉·弗里德里希（Israel and Zizsla Friedrich）。所以在我能帮斯科隆斯卡家处理房产问题之前，我必须先从我曾祖父母那里继承这栋房子。但第一道障碍是，在你开始继承程序之前，你必须在遗嘱登记处提交一份死亡证明。但我没有死亡证明，因为他们死于大屠杀。
So I went to Auschwitz. But, of course, Auschwitz had no records of my great grandparents having been there. I don't even know if they were there. I know they didn't survive. And, even if they had survived, they would be like, 130.
所以我去了奥斯威辛。但当然，奥斯威辛没有我曾祖父母去过那里的记录。我甚至不知道他们是否在那里。我知道他们没有生还。而且，就算他们幸存下来，他们现在也该有130岁了。
So they still needed you to prove that they were dead, even though if they were alive they'd be 130 years old?
所以他们还是需要你证明他们已经死了，尽管如果他们活着的话也该130岁了？
Correct.
没错。
So I figure, well, OK, at least let me prove how old they are. So let me try and find their birth certificates. But I go to the Bedzin records for that time period, and there's no records of my family at all. Meaning that they probably weren't in Bedzin at that time. They must have been in a smaller village.
所以我心想，好吧，至少让我证明他们多大年纪了。让我试着找找他们的出生证明。但当我去查那个时期的本津记录时，根本没有我家族的记录。这意味着他们当时可能不在本津。他们一定在某个更小的村庄。
So I basically spend six months driving around to villages that I know have the surname Friedrich in them. And I would pull up these giant genealogy books that have birth, marriage, and death records. And they are these big, dusty, yellow books. And I turn the pages in search of my great-grandparents. And, actually, my friend translating the marriage record of my great-great-uncle, had a reference to a town called [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. So I go to [UNINTELLIGIBLE] and I actually find my great-grandfather's birth certificate.
所以我花了六个月的时间开车去那些我知道有“弗里德里希”这个姓氏的村庄。我会翻阅那些巨大的家谱书，里面有出生、结婚和死亡记录。它们是大而布满灰尘的黄纸书。我翻找着我曾祖父母的名字。其实，我翻译我曾外祖父结婚记录的朋友提到过一个叫[听不清]的镇子。所以我去了那里，竟然真的找到了我曾祖父的出生证明。
So I get this record. And then I give it to my lawyer and he's like, "Well, OK, what about your great-grandmother?" And actually, I still have no idea where she was born, so I don't have that record. I said, OK, I can prove that she gave birth in 1895. And they're like, OK, well, we'll see. But in any event-- so first we apply to get their death certificate, which ultimately takes three and a half years, to get a death certificate.
我拿到了这份记录。把它交给我的律师，他说：“好吧，那曾祖母呢？”其实我还是不知道她出生在哪里，所以我没有那份记录。我说，好吧，我可以证明她在1895年生过孩子。他们说，好吧，我们会看的。总之，我们先申请获得了死亡证明，最终花了三年半才拿到。
But to make the inheritance procedures move forward, she needs documentation on each and every one of her great-grandfather's heirs, all of whom have a potential claim on the building.
但为了推进继承程序，她需要她曾祖父每一位继承人的文件，他们每个人都对这栋楼有潜在的所有权要求。
I'm not the only heir. My great-grandparents had eight children, four of whom died in the war, four of whom survived, including my grandfather. And three of his siblings who moved to the United States before the war. And of those three siblings, one had four children, two had two children, all of their children had children, and there were great-great-grandchildren, and something like 50 heirs that I could count living at the time.
我不只是唯一的继承人。我曾祖父母有八个孩子，其中四个死于战争，四个幸存下来，包括我爷爷。还有他在战前移居美国的三个兄弟姐妹。那三个兄弟姐妹中，一个有四个孩子，两个有两个孩子，所有孩子都有孩子，还有曾孙辈，当时我能数的出的继承人大约有50位。
So for every heir that we were going to declare in the process, and ultimately we ended up choosing a representative from each branch of the family, we had to prove the entire chain between us and my great-grandparents. So for me alone, I had to have my grandfather's birth and death record, my mother's birth, marriage, and death record, to prove why her name had changed from Friedrich to Einhorn. And then every record that came from the United States had to be sent to a Polish Consulate. And not just any Polish Consulate, because different Polish Consulates are responsible for different American states.
所以对于我们过程中要申报的每一位继承人——我们最终选择每个家族分支的一位代表——我们必须证明我们和曾祖父母之间完整的链条。对我个人而言，我必须有我爷爷的出生和死亡证明，我母亲的出生、结婚和死亡记录，以证明为什么她的姓氏从弗里德里希变成了艾因霍恩。而且所有来自美国的文件都必须送到波兰领事馆。还不是随便哪个领事馆，因为不同的波兰领事馆负责不同的美国州。
So my birth certificate in Detroit, had to go to the consulate in Chicago. While my grandfather's death certificate from Atlanta had to go to the consulate in Washington. And meanwhile, this whole process is going on, I've now spent-- well I paid $2,000 to my lawyer, I spent hundreds and hundreds of dollars on these documents, ordering the documents, all this time. But every time I go to the Skowronski's, they're still having problems. Because they still can't collect the rent, they still have to pay the taxes, they still have all these problems.
我的底特律出生证明必须送到芝加哥领事馆，而我爷爷在亚特兰大的死亡证明必须送到华盛顿的领事馆。与此同时，这个过程一直在进行，我已经花了……好吧，我付给律师2000美元，花了成百上千美元订购这些文件，费了这么多时间。但每次我去斯科隆斯卡家，他们依然有问题。因为他们依然不能收房租，依然要付税，依然面对所有这些麻烦。
And so I'm showing up and they say, "So, hey, what's going on the property?" And I said, "Well, you know, it's going to take a long time." But they become increasingly frustrated with me.
所以我去的时候他们说：“那么，嘿，房产到底怎么样了？”我说：“嗯，你知道，这需要很长时间。”但他们对我越来越失望。
And do they feel like you're trying to steal the property from them?
他们是不是觉得你在试图从他们手里窃取房产？
I think that they just think that I'm not trying hard enough. They don't understand why they're still having these problems, two years after they met me. And there was a couple of incidents where they started to yell at me, and they'd say-- we were actually arguing over who owned the house. They insisted my grandfather owned the house. And I would say, "No, it's my great-grandfather, that's why it's so complicated." And they'd say,"No, your grandfather owned it, and he gave it to our mother." And I'd say, "No, look it says on the deed, Israel Friedrich, he is my great-grandfather." And they would say, "No, your grandfather owned it."
我觉得他们只是认为我没尽力。他们不明白为什么在见到我两年后，他们还会遇到这些问题。有几次他们冲我大吼大叫，我们当时还在争论到底谁拥有这栋房子。他们坚持说我爷爷拥有这栋房子。我说：“不，是我的曾祖父，这就是为什么这么复杂。”他们说：“不，是你爷爷拥有的，他把它给了我们的母亲。”我说：“不，你看，产权证明上写着，以色列·弗里德里希，他是我曾祖父。”他们会说：“不，是你爷爷拥有的。”
And we just do this. I mean, we did this for a year, basically. Arguing over who owned the house on the deed.
我们就这样……我们基本上这样争论了一年。争论谁是产权证明上的房主。
It's during these months where she is arguing with the Skowronski's, and driving around to records offices in these tiny villages, Erin has an entire second line of detective work that she's doing. She has a stack of letters, and other documents, and she's getting these translated from German and Polish and Yiddish and Swedish and Hebrew. And as she does this, a whole other version of the family history-- these two family histories, I guess-- slowly begins to emerge.
就在这几个月里，她和斯科隆斯卡家争论不休，在那些小村庄的档案馆间奔波，艾琳同时也在进行第二条线索的侦探工作。她有一堆信件和其他文件，正在把这些德语、波兰语、意第绪语、瑞典语和希伯来语的文档翻译出来。随着工作的进行，家族史的另一个完整版本——或者说这两段家族史——慢慢浮出水面。
And it is not a pretty history. It is not in a heroic Polish woman, and a grateful father now in America. Erin found out that there was a reason the two families had not been in contact for years. It was more than they had just fallen out of touch. One of the first letters that Erin reads is from May 22, 1962. Nearly two decades after the end of the war.
那并不是一段美好的历史，不是一个英雄的波兰女性和一个在美国的感激父亲的故事。艾琳发现，两家人多年没有联系是有原因的，不仅仅是因为断了联络。艾琳读到的第一封信日期是1962年5月22日，距离战争结束已近二十年。
And this was actually a handwritten letter, in Polish, from Honorata Skowronski to my grandfather. The letter starts out, "Dear Mr. Friedrich, I am writing to you after such a long time because we haven't been corresponding. Because you are a man of honor. I have been waiting for your letter, and maybe you have been waiting for mine. Now I'm writing to you that I am sorry. You may be angry at me, because of the letters I wrote to you. I also was offended because of the way you wrote to me, but let's forget about that. I was happy to have someone abroad, and I felt that you were my brother. And you are so cold to me. I don't want much. All I want is us to live in peace, because life is so short. We should be kind to each other.
这是一封波兰语手写信，是奥诺拉塔写给我爷爷的。信的开头写道：“亲爱的弗里德里希先生，时隔这么久才写信给你，是因为我们一直没有联络。你是位有荣誉感的人。我一直在等你的信，也许你也在等我的。现在写信给你，是因为我很抱歉。你可能因为我写的那些信而生我的气。我对你回信的方式也感到受挫，但让我们忘记这一切吧。我很高兴在国外有亲人，我一直觉得你是我的兄弟，但你对我太冷漠了。我别无所求，只希望我们能平静地生活，因为生命很短暂。我们应该善待彼此。
Mr Friedrich, let's forget about it. I'm just curious how you are doing? Is Arentka married? Does she have family? Is she doing all right? Are you in good health? How is your family? Are  you still close with your brothers and your sister?
弗里德里希先生，让我们忘掉过去吧。我只是好奇你过得怎么样？阿伦特卡（Arentka）结婚了吗？有家庭了吗？她还好吗？你身体健康吗？你的家人怎么样？你还和你的兄弟姐妹保持联络吗？
Regarding the house, Mr. Friedrich, I will write everything about it. There are eight tenants, and they pay 40 zloty each per month, with all the utilities. If you don't believe that I am able to manage your property, you can ask anybody or the municipality. I have just carried out a renovation but the money goes to municipality, so I have nothing left. At least the house is kept in order, and is well-maintained.
关于房子，弗里德里希先生，我会写清楚所有情况。有八个租户，每人每月付40兹罗提，包含所有水电费。如果你不相信我有能力管理你的财产，你可以问任何人或市政部门。我刚做过翻修，但钱都被市政部门拿走了，所以我什么都没剩下。至少房子保持整洁，维护得很好。
Mr. Friedrich, maybe you could come see your property? You could see its condition. I would be very happy to see you here with Arentka. I would like to see my daughter. I would be very honored to see her. And if you cannot come to Poland, maybe I could visit you and then I could see how the world looks.
弗里德里希先生，也许你能来看看你的房产？你可以看看状况。如果能在这里见到你和阿伦特卡，我会非常高兴。我想见见我的女儿。如果能见到她，我会感到非常荣幸。如果你不能来波兰，也许我可以去见你，这样我能看看外面的世界。
Maybe I will write some more in the next letter. Best regards to you, to Arentka, and to your family. Skowronski."
也许我会在下封信里多写一点。向你、阿伦特卡和你的家人致以最诚挚的问候。斯科隆斯卡。”
That letter just is so full of intrigue of what were they fighting about?
那封信里充满了悬念，他们到底在争论什么？
Right, you say, well-- I had some idea that there had been a conflict there. The comments my mother would make, like, "Oh, she only did it for the money." And there was also a family story, my mother had said, about how Honorata had once asked my grandfather to send her a Chevrolet. He was in Detroit, I guess. That's where Chevrolets come from.
对，你说得对……我确实知道那里有过冲突。我母亲说的话，比如“噢，她只是为了钱才这么做”。我母亲还讲过一个家族故事，说奥诺拉塔曾要求我爷爷给她寄一辆雪佛兰。他当时在底特律，我想，那是雪佛兰产地。
I knew there was something there, but, then I had more letters translated.
我知道里面有猫腻，于是我又翻译了更多信件。
There was one from January, 1959, that her grandfather wrote to a lawyer in Poland, apparently concerned about what was going on at his house. He tells the lawyer that he's just found out that Skowronski doesn't pay the taxes in the building, and got into debt, because the city seized some factory buildings that were part of the property. Quote, "All of this happened without my knowledge, so I hope you can clear this up."
有一封1959年1月的信，是我爷爷写给波兰的一位律师的，他显然担心房子的状况。他告诉律师，他刚发现斯科隆斯卡不付房产税，导致欠债，因为市政部门查封了一些作为财产一部分的工厂建筑。引用原话：“所有这些都在我不知情的情况下发生了，我希望你能帮我清理掉。”
Then, about six months later, July 17, 1959, he gets a letter from somebody in Bedzin, probably a neighbor. Erin can't actually tell, because the name is illegible.
然后，大约六个月后，1959年7月17日，他收到了本津某人的一封信，可能是一个邻居。艾琳其实看不出来，因为名字字迹模糊。
It's four pages of single spaced, typed, really dense. It's an absolute screed. Dated July 17, 1959 in Bedzin, and addressed to my grandfather on Cloverlawn Street in Detroit. "Dear sir," the writer of the letter addresses him. "I don't like prying into other people's affairs, especially as I have some disagreements with Skowronski, caused by her. Hoping that this letter will remain absolutely confidential, I don't want any other disagreements with such a rude person as Skowronski, I find it necessary to inform you about the situation, because I wouldn't like you to lose your house. These are the facts.
那是四页单倍行距、打印得密密麻麻的信。这是一份严厉的指控书，日期是1959年7月17日，来自本津，寄往底特律克洛弗劳恩街（Cloverlawn Street）的我爷爷。“亲爱的先生，”写信人称呼他。“我不喜欢打探别人的私事，尤其是我和斯科隆斯卡之间因为她本人原因有些分歧。希望这封信严格保密，我不想再和斯科隆斯卡这种粗鲁的人发生分歧，但我认为有必要告知你这一情况，因为我不希望你失去你的房子。以下是事实。
One, Skowronski administrates your property in a very robbing way. She scrounges all that she can out of the house without investing anything. She doesn't maintain it well, doesn't care about renovations, even doesn't want to have it removed from the municipal funds. That is why the house is untidy and rundown. Anyway, she doesn't seem to know what order is, and she started growing pigs in the cellar.
第一，斯科隆斯卡以一种极其掠夺的方式管理你的财产。她从房子里榨取一切能榨取的，却没有任何投资。她没有维护好，不关心翻修，甚至不想从市政资金中拨出费用。这就是为什么房子既不整洁又破旧。总之，她似乎不知道什么是秩序，而且她开始在地下室养猪。
Worse, Skowronski doesn't pay the taxes as well. And she doesn't pay the municipality money she collects from the occupants for water, et cetera. Skowronski doesn't have time and goodwill to take care of the house. She deals with trading, and is out all the time. She has constant problems with police and cases at the court. Recently, she had a very serious case for abusing her children. She may even go to prison for a long time. And then the house will be abandoned completely."
更糟的是，斯科隆斯卡也不交税。而且她也不把从住户那里收来的水费等钱交给市政部门。斯科隆斯卡没有时间和善意去照顾房子。她热衷交易，整天在外。她经常遇到警察问题和法院诉讼。最近，她还因为虐待孩子而有严重的官司。她甚至可能要坐很久的牢。到时候房子就会彻底被废弃了。”
So, as you're reading this letter. what are you thinking?
当你读到这封信时，你在想什么？
I'm thinking, no wonder he was freaking out. No wonder he was angry. No wonder he wrote her a presumably nasty letter which would have prompted a nasty fight, which would have caused her, several years later, to have to write that apology. And to plead for forgiveness and try to get in his-- "Mr. Friedrich, I consider you my brother. I want to see my daughter." She feels badly that they'd had this fight.
我在想，难怪他会崩溃。难怪他会愤怒。难怪他写了一封推测起来很恶毒的信，这会引发一场激烈的争吵，导致她在几年后不得不写那封道歉信。并恳求原谅，试图进入他的圈子——“弗里德里希先生，我视你为我的兄弟。我想见我的女儿。”她对自己引发的那场争吵感到难过。
And when you're reading this, do you feel like she's probably in the wrong?
当你读到这些时，你觉得她可能是理亏的那一方吗？
I think both sides clearly had a legitimate position. Even if-- you know what? So she was raising pigs in the cellar. But she saved my mother's life. And I think probably if Mrs. Skowronski was writing to him, and asking him to send her things, that's probably because she had the perception of America that many people do. That it's this nation of wealth. And my grandfather had been wealthy before the war, so he is this rich Jew in America. And why is he giving her grief about this house? Why doesn't he just pay the? Debts
我认为双方显然都有正当的立场。即使……你瞧？她确实在地下室养猪。但她救了我母亲的生命。我想，如果斯科隆斯卡夫人写信给他要求寄东西，那可能是因为她对美国有许多人都有的那种认知：这是一个富有的国家。而我爷爷战前富有，所以他就是那个在美国的富有的犹太人。为什么他要在这栋房子的问题上为难她？为什么他不能直接付清欠款？
And, of course, he was very poor, very struggling in the United States. He had had epilepsy from being beaten on the head in Auschwitz. And though he was a tool and die maker, and should have been doing well, he would have epileptic seizures on the floor of auto plants. And then would be promptly fired, several decades before the ADA.
当然，他当时在美国非常贫穷，在挣扎。他因为在奥斯威辛头部受过重击而患有癫痫。虽然他是个模具制造工，本应过得不错，但他会在汽车工厂的地板上癫痫发作。然后被迅速解雇，那是在《美国残疾人法案》（ADA）出台几十年前。
And if all this weren't complicated enough, Erin discovered that Honorata Skowronski had been awarded a medal from Yad Vashem, the Holocaust memorial in Jerusalem. A medal that nobody in Erin's family knew about. The medal's called the Righteous Among the Nation's medal. And it's given to non-Jews who risked their own lives to save Jews during the Holocaust. Because of the medal, Honorata also got a pension from a Jewish organization in her old age.
如果所有这些还不够复杂，艾琳还发现奥诺拉塔曾获得以色列耶路撒冷大屠杀纪念馆颁发的奖章。这是一枚艾琳家人中没人知道的奖章。这枚奖章叫“国际义人奖章”。它颁发给在二战期间冒生命危险救助犹太人的非犹太人。因为这枚奖章，奥诺拉塔在晚年还得到了一家犹太组织的养老金。
But the most interesting thing in Honorata's Yad Vashem file, and the most helpful thing in piecing together the past, was a statement that she wrote, typed in polish, dated September 7, 1983, that laid out more clearly and systematically than anything else, point by point, how Honorata viewed what had happened between the two families over the years. Erin reads.
但在奥诺拉塔的档案馆案卷中，最有趣也是最有助于还原过去的部分，是一份她本人写下的声明。打印版，波兰语，日期是1983年9月7日。它比任何其他东西都更清晰、更系统地、逐点列出了奥诺拉塔对这些年来两个家庭之间发生之事的看法。艾琳读道。
"This case concerns the help I gave to the Jewish child under the German occupation in Poland. During the German occupation, I lived Dombrowa Gornicza, Parkowa Street. Mr. Friedrich, and his one and a half year old daughter, Arenna, lived in Bedzin, [UNINTELLIGIBLE] Street, number 20, and his wife was taken away to the ghetto.
“此案涉及我在德国占领波兰期间给予犹太儿童的帮助。德国占领期间，我住在栋布罗瓦-古尔尼恰（Dombrowa Gornicza）的帕尔科瓦街。弗里德里希先生和他一岁半的女儿阿伦娜（Arenna）住在本津，[听不清]街20号，他的妻子被带到了隔都。
In July of the same year, I took his daughter, Arenna. I prepared a birth certificate for Arenna, with my family's surname. I carried the child on my own back from the border while escaping from Dombrowa to [? Myehov ?]. And so, as not to let the people know that she was Jewish, I used to change the color of her hair. In November, 1945, Mr. Friedrich came back to get Arenna. She was five years old, and I gave her back to him in the presence of two witnesses. She was crying very loud. She didn't know her father, and she was more attached to me than to her father. She was crying and calling me, "Mommy, take me home with you."
那年7月，我带走了他的女儿阿伦娜。我为阿伦娜准备了一份带有我夫姓的出生证明。我背着孩子从边境逃离，从栋布罗瓦逃到[听不清]。为了不让人们知道她是犹太人，我常改变她的头发颜色。1945年11月，弗里德里希先生回来接阿伦娜。她当时五岁，我在两位见证人在场的情况下把她交还给他。她哭得很大声。她不认识自己的父亲，她比跟亲生父亲更亲近我。她哭着叫我：‘妈妈，带我回家吧。’
We made a photo of me, Mr. Friedrich, and the child as a souvenir when I was giving the child to Mr. Friedrich. I don't have this picture now because I've lost it. When they were about to depart, Mr. Friedrich promised to pay me back and told me that until the end of my life I would be all right and he would never forget about me. And all I got was the picture of Arenna in Sweden as a six-year-old child.
我们在我把孩子交还给弗里德里希先生时，拍了一张我和他以及孩子的照片作为纪念。我现在没有这张照片了，因为弄丢了。他们即将离开时，弗里德里希先生承诺会回报我，并告诉我余生都会照顾我，绝不会忘记我。结果我只得到了阿伦娜六岁时在瑞典的一张照片。
This was for all I did during the occupation. For hiding and taking care of the child. This is a very short summary of my taking care of Arenna.
这就是我占领期间所做的一切的回报。为了隐藏和照顾孩子。这是我照顾阿伦娜的非常简短的总结。
I used to correspond with Mr. Friedrich until 1950, but Mr. Friedrich hasn't responded until now. Right now I am in a grave situation, paralyzed, and I can't walk. All I want is to live until the moment when Mr. Friedrich will thank me. The Jewish Historical Institute in Warsaw has all of my data, but I need to have all of the confirmation from Mr. Friedrich that I kept his daughter during the occupation."
我曾与弗里德里希先生保持通信直到1950年，但直到现在他都没有再回信。现在我处境悲惨，瘫痪在床，无法行走。我只想活到弗里德里希先生感谢我的那一刻。华沙的犹太历史研究所掌握了我所有的资料，但我需要弗里德里希先生确认我曾在占领期间收留了他的女儿。”
At points during that letter, she seems so bitter. "This is all I got."
在那封信的某些地方，她看起来非常苦涩。“这就是我得到的一切。”
Yeah, and my family's version of events is that, in fact, they had plied her with gifts. That they had sent her all kinds of things and that she always wanted more. And as far as they're concerned, my grandfather blew them off, completely neglected them, completely mistreated their mother. She died wishing he would come back, wishing her daughter would come back, resenting my grandfather.
是的，我家族的版本是，实际上他们曾用礼物填补过她的需求。他们曾寄给她各种东西，但她总是想要更多。在他们看来，我爷爷敷衍他们，完全忽视他们，完全虐待了他们的母亲。她临死前一直希望他能回来，希望她的女儿能回来，怨恨我爷爷。
But hearing the story about your mom crying when her dad shows up at the end of the war, and she's got to leave the Polish family, it seems clear from that that they really loved your mom.
但听到你母亲在战争结束时父亲出现而大哭的故事，她必须离开波兰家庭，这似乎很清楚，他们真的很爱你母亲。
I think they probably did, and I'm sure-- I know for sure that she cried, because that was her memory. She remembered having cried when her father came. And I'm sure it was emotional for them. I mean, I don't think-- Wieslaw Skowronski's tears the day I met him, in May of 2001, were unfakeable. I mean, they were sincere. And not just that day. Every time I would go back there, his wife would be going on about the house, and there would be this moment where suddenly he would seem removed from the conversation. And he would be looking at a photograph, and he would start to cry.
我想他们可能确实爱她，而且我确定……我知道肯定她哭过，因为那是她的记忆。她记得父亲来的时候她哭过。我相信这对他们来说也很感伤。我的意思是，我不认为……2001年5月我见到维斯瓦夫·斯科隆斯卡那天，他的眼泪是无法假装的。他们是真诚的。不仅那天，每次我再回去，他的妻子还在没完没了地唠叨房子，总会有那么一刻，他会突然从谈话中抽离出来。他会看着一张照片，然后开始流泪。
It's just so interesting in the light of all of this, that your mom, and everybody else in your family, decided that the Skowronski's were just in it for the money. Do you know what I mean? It seems like from everything that you're finding that actually the Skowronski's were very sweet with her, and that she loved them. And it seems like in a way, the most convenient thing for everyone to believe for her to move on with her life, for her to believe and for your grandfather believe, was just that this Polish family had just done it for the money. You know, to wipe out any fondness she had for them.
考虑到这一切，你母亲和你家里的其他人认定斯科隆斯卡家只是为了钱，这真的很有意思。你明白我的意思吗？从你发现的一切来看，实际上斯科隆斯卡家对她非常好，她也爱他们。似乎在某种程度上，对每个人来说，为了继续生活，为了让她自己和你爷爷相信，最方便的说法就是这个波兰家庭只是为了钱。你知道，这样就能抹去她对他们的任何喜爱。
Yeah. I mean, I think-- maybe it was a convenience. There's no way it was just for the money. She just didn't want to confront all that. And her coping mechanism, it's a very popular coping mechanism, is denial. And that's what she did. That was why she told me her story as it wasn't a big deal. She specifically told me, "I had an easy to childhood. I was lucky. I was always loved." And it was easy for her to kind of blow off how traumatic it must have been to be torn from place to place.
是的。我的意思是，我想……也许这是一种方便之举。绝不可能只是为了钱。她只是不想面对这一切。而她的应对机制——这是一种非常流行的应对机制——就是否认。这就是她所做的。这就是为什么她把故事讲得好像没什么大不了。她专门跟我说：“我的童年过得很轻松。我很幸运。我一直被爱着。”而且她很容易就把被从一个地方拖到另一个地方是多么痛苦这件事给抛之脑后了。
Which is why years later she's watching baby Jessica on television being ripped away from her adoptive parents, and the whole country is upset over how traumatic it was to watch this little girl, this two year old, being taken from the only parents she'd known. And my mother's flipping off the TV in disgust and saying, "Ugh. That kid'll be fine. The same thing happened to me."
这也是为什么多年后，她在电视上看到“洁西卡宝宝”（Baby Jessica）被从养父母身边强行带走，全国都在为这件令人痛苦的事而难过，为一个两岁女孩被带离她仅知的父母而心碎时，我母亲却鄙夷地冲电视翻白眼说：“呃，那孩子会没事的。我也经历过同样的事。”
Erin's hope, of course, had been that by going to Poland, by doing all these things, she was going to reawaken some feelings in her mom about her own past, and about what happened during the war, and what happened with the Skowronski's. And then, just as Erin was beginning this process of meeting with the Skowronski's, right after that first visit with Wieslaw, her mom dies. Cancer
当然，艾琳的希望是，通过去波兰，做这些事情，她能唤起母亲对自己过去，对战时发生的事，以及对斯科隆斯卡一家所发生之事的某些感受。就在艾琳开始与斯科隆斯卡家会面，就在第一次与维斯瓦夫见面后，她母亲去世了，死于癌症。
For whatever reason, I just couldn't break this news to them. Because Wieslaw had been so excited about seeing my mother again, after all these years. I mean, she had been essentially dead to him. He didn't know where she was, she had vanished. She was gone for his life for 50-som years and then, in early May, I show up and say, "She's alive. She's 59 years old. She's great."
不管出于什么原因，我就是没法把这个消息告诉他们。因为维斯瓦夫一直非常期待在这些年后再次见到我母亲。我的意思是，她对他来说本质上已经死了。他不知道她在哪里，她消失了。她在他的生活中消失了50多年，然后，在5月初，我出现并说：“她还活着。她59岁了。她很好。”
I just couldn't show up again, in July, when I got back to Poland, and say "Yeah, actually, no. Unfortunately she's died." I just couldn't do it. I ended up telling him several months later, after preparing him by breaking the news that she had cancer. Then she was getting worse, and it was getting bad. Just so it wouldn't be so shocking.
我在7月份回到波兰时，实在无法再次出现并说：“是的，其实不，不幸的是她去世了。”我做不到。几个月后，在我通过透露她患有癌症的消息做好铺垫后，我才最终告诉了他。当时她的病情正在恶化。这样就不会太震惊。
When I finally tell them that my mother has died in, I think, October of 2001, they're kind of sad. And they're like, "Oh, I'm sorry." And then a few minutes pass, and then they're like, "OK, so what's going on with the house?" My heart just sank. You know? Is it just you think I'm here to do what my grandfather should have done and that's it for you?
当我最终在2001年10月左右告诉他们我母亲去世时，他们有点难过。他们说：“噢，我很遗憾。”然后几分钟过去了，他们又说：“好吧，那房子怎么办？”我的心都沉下去了。你知道吗？你是觉得我来这里是为了做我爷爷本该做的事，除此之外就没别的了吗？
Suddenly you were actually involved in the same relationship with them that your grandfather had been.
突然间，你其实卷入了和你爷爷当年与他们同样的关系中。
We ended up, I think, in a lot of ways, reliving the same thing. I think my grandfather, in some ways, may have been hurt by these letters he'd gotten from Honorata Skowronski asking for things. And he was, after a while, he says, "Stop asking me for things. I'm grateful for all that you did, but I can only do so much." And I think I started feeling the exact same way.
我想在很多方面，我们最终重演了同样的事情。我认为我爷爷在某些方面可能因为收到奥诺拉塔索要东西的信而感到受伤。一段时间后他说：“别再向我要求东西了。我感激你所做的一切，但我只能做这么多。”我想我开始有同样的感觉。
Without this family, I don't exist. So my very existence is thanks to them, or thanks to Honorata Skowronski. But after awhile, I'm like, "Look, I'm trying. I'm doing what I can. I'm trying to help you, but I can only do so much."
没有这家人，我就不存在。所以我的生命本身要归功于他们，或者说归功于奥诺拉塔·斯科隆斯卡。但过了一会儿，我说：“听着，我尽力了。我在做我能做的。我在试图帮助你们，但我只能做这么多。”
Should I have offered to pay their taxes? And how long does this debt last? So, she saves a life. Now, saving a life is multi-generational heroism, you know? If I have children or my brother has children, that we have children, our family lives on. So maybe the gratitude should be a multi-generational gratitude. But now it's 2005-- actually, Wieslaw passed away in 2002, a year after I met him.
我是否应该主动提出帮他们付税？这笔债要持续多久？所以，她救了一条命。救命是一种代际英雄主义，你知道吗？如果我有孩子，或者我兄弟有孩子，我们的家庭就会延续下去。所以也许这种感激也应该是代际的感激。但现在是2005年了——其实维斯瓦夫在2002年，也就是我见到他一年后就去世了。
This is the man you first met when you got there, yeah.
这就是你刚到那里时见到的那个人，是的。
So he has passed away. My mother has passed away. My grandfather is gone. Honorata is gone. And now the person who's asking me to help them is the second wife of the son of the woman who saved my mother.
所以他去世了。我母亲去世了。我爷爷不在了。奥诺拉塔也不在了。现在要求我帮忙的人是救我母亲那女人的儿子的第二任妻子。
Just last year, in 2004, the family became so impatient with Erin, that they filed their own claim, under Polish squatter's law, saying they'd lived there for 30 years and they should get the building. Which led to other complications. The building is actually a duplex, and the owners of the other half of the building are a family in Israel. And they do not want to give up the building to the squatters, and they'd been trying to get Erin to take their side of things, and fight this Skowronski's.
就在去年，2004年，那家人对艾琳变得非常不耐烦，他们根据波兰的“占屋法”提出了自己的所有权要求，声称他们在那儿住了30年，应该得到这栋建筑。这导致了其他并发症。这栋建筑其实是双拼房，另一半的所有者是住在以色列的一家人。他们不想把建筑让给占屋者，他们一直试图让艾琳站到他们这一边，对抗斯科隆斯卡一家。
Which means that people have been angry with Erin for years now about this building, and, whichever way that it works out, whoever ends up owning the building, somebody is still going to be mad at Erin.
这意味着多年来人们一直因为这栋建筑对艾琳感到愤怒。而且，无论结果如何，无论最后谁拥有这栋楼，总有人会因为这件事对艾琳感到不满。
So you go to Poland thinking you are going to have this sweet and nostalgic rejoining with these people, and you find yourself to be their reluctant, absentee, resented landlord.
所以你怀着和这些人甜蜜重逢、追忆往昔的心情前往波兰，结果却发现自己成了他们不情愿的、缺席的、被怨恨的房东。
I certainly end up stepping into a role I hadn't anticipated. You know, I kind of thought, in a lot of ways, that the history was this book. And I was reaching up to a high shelf and fishing this book off the shelf. And I would bring the book home, and show it to my friends and family and say look, isn't it beautiful? I never anticipated that the characters in the book lived on and that, in fact, the book was all beat up and that the book actually had resentments and feelings and--
我确实陷入了一个我没预料到的角色。你知道，我在很多方面觉得，历史就像一本书。我伸手去够高处的书架，把书拿下来。我会把书带回家，给朋友和家人看，说：看，这不是挺美的吗？我从未预料到书里的角色还活着，而且事实上，书已经破损不堪，书里还充满了怨恨和情绪……
In fact, that you were going to be in the book, fighting it out with them.
事实上，你是要进入书里，和他们进行斗争。
I'm certainly a conflicted character. And not necessarily as a heroine. I'm actually stepping into the role, in many ways, of the villain.
我确实是一个充满矛盾的角色。而且未必是女主角。我其实在很多方面正步入反派的角色。
Erin Einhorn, she's a reporter for the New York Daily News , and she has written a book about her experience with the house and the Skowronski's. It's just come out. It's called The Pages in Between .
艾琳·艾因霍恩，《纽约每日新闻》的记者，她写了一本关于她与房子和斯科隆斯卡家经历的书。书刚出版，叫《中间的页码》（The Pages in Between）。
[MUSIC - "EVERYTHING I OWN" BY KEN BOOTHE]
[音乐 - “EVERYTHING I OWN” BY KEN BOOTHE]
Coming up, a man gets a chance to settle a 17-year-old score with help of the Chicago police. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，一个男人在芝加哥警方的帮助下，有机会了结一桩17年前的夙愿。稍后从芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台继续收听。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, "Settling the Score." We have two stories today, and each one is about somebody in a situation where one things leads to another without them exactly sure where it is going. And they're forced to figure out some kind of past, which has been lost. And, in the end, you get to the question, can money solve certain kinds of problems? Especially big emotional things that have been brewing for years.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，带来不同类型的故事。今天节目的主题是“了结夙愿”。我们今天有两个故事，每个故事的主角都处在一种情况中，一件事情接着另一件事，而他们并不完全确定事态会走向何方。他们被迫去理清某种已经遗失的过去。最终，你会被问到：金钱能解决某些问题吗？尤其是那些积压多年的巨大情感问题。
We've arrived at act two of our program, Act Two, "The Things that Money Can Buy." Beau O'Reilly, who as been on our program a bunch of times, he tells the story.
我们来到了节目的第二部分，第二部分，“金钱能买到的东西”。曾在我们节目出现多次的博·奥赖利（Beau O'Reilly）来讲述这个故事。
A warning to listeners, before it begins, that at some point in this story Beau is going to refer to a way that people hide contraband, in their body cavities, and then remove it from said body cavities. But he's going to use words more explicit than the words that I'm using right now. OK, so you are pre-warned, if you find that shocking.
在故事开始前给听众一个警告，故事中某个时刻博会提到人们在体腔内藏匿违禁品，然后从体腔取出。他使用的词汇会比我刚才用的更直白。好了，如果你觉得这很令人震惊，请做好准备。
When Beau's story begins, he is flying back from overseas, from Germany.
博的故事开始时，他正从海外，从德国飞回来。
And as we come into O'Hare, they say over the loudspeaker, whatever, the intercom, "Would Richard O'Reilly"-- which is my real name-- "Would Mr. O'Reilly, would you please stay in your seat when we land." Now I realize that when they say, stay in your seat when you land, don't do it. Just get up and leave with everybody else. Because it's not good news. They're not there to help you probably.
当我们接近奥黑尔机场时，他们在扩音器——随便什么，对讲机里说：“请理查德·奥赖利”——这是我的真名——“请奥赖利先生在着陆后留在座位上。”现在我意识到，当他们说落地后留在座位上，千万别听。一定要像其他人一样立刻起身离开。因为这不是好消息。他们大概不是去帮你的。
So we land. And I sit in my seat. And everybody else gets off. And I'm the only person in this whole plane. And then an official looking airport person comes up to me, with the stewardess, and says "Would you just please come to the front of the plane?" And now I'm asking, is there something wrong? Has something happened?
所以我们着陆了，我坐在座位上。其他人都走了。整架飞机上只有我一个人。然后一个看起来像官方人员的机场工作人员带着空姐走过来对我说：“请你到飞机前部来一下好吗？”现在我在问自己，出什么问题了吗？发生了什么事？
And I'm walking with a cane. And this cane I've gotten in Germany, because I've hurt my back. And I got this cane in Germany. And it's a little nondescript, wooden cane. Except that it has a bullet on the end of it. And so the point of this cane is this bullet. And apparently that's a very normal period between the wars where they made canes and they stuck these bullets on the end. And it's a certain cane that they all have.
我拄着拐杖走着。这根拐杖是我在德国弄到的，因为我弄伤了背。这是根平平无奇的木拐杖。除了末端有一个子弹头。拐杖的重点就是这个子弹。显然，两次世界大战之间有一个非常正常的时期，那时人们制造拐杖并在末端镶上子弹。这是一种他们都有的特定拐杖。
And so I'm walking with his cane, and there are two Chicago policemen there. And The policeman grab me on both arms, on either side, and they ask me to put my hands behind my back. And one of them takes the cane, and they put me against the wall, and they ask me where my weapon is. "Where is it?" And I say, "I don't have a weapon." And they search my body, they hand search my body.
所以我拄着这根拐杖走着，那里有两个芝加哥警察。警察抓住我的双臂，问我把手背到身后。其中一个拿走了拐杖，他们把我推向墙壁，问我的武器在哪里。“在哪儿？”我说：“我没有武器。”他们搜我的身，亲手搜了我的身。
And it turns out the weapon seems to be this cane. That this cane has been reported. And then they say, "You're under arrest." And they read me my Miranda rights. And I say, "What am I under arrest for?" And they say, "We don't know, there's a warrant for your arrest." And they handcuff me behind my back. There's a Chicago police station in O'Hare airport, sort of underneath O'Hare airport, which I never knew.
结果武器似乎就是这根拐杖。这根拐杖被举报了。然后他们说：“你被捕了。”他们宣读了我的米兰达权利。我说：“我因为什么被捕？”他们说：“我们不知道，有一张逮捕令。”他们给我戴上手铐。奥黑尔机场底下有一个芝加哥警察局，我以前从不知道。
And they take me down in there and there's holding cells. It's pretty small. And I sit there for some period of time, maybe about an hour and a half, two hours or something. And then they come back in, it's a different cop, it's a bigger, older cop. And they say, we're going to take you into the city. They put me in the back seat of a squad car, they drive me into the city. And by now it's night time. It's dark. I think when we landed it was still day.
他们把我带到那下面，有拘留室。很小。我在那儿坐了大概一个半小时，两小时什么的。然后他们回来了，是另一个警察，更壮、更老一点的警察。他们说，我们要把你带进城里。他们把我塞进警车的后座，开车进城。现在已经是晚上了。天黑了。我记得落地时还是白天的。
And they take me to a building, which turns out to be down in the Loop. And they take me out and they take me through a basement, and up a an escalator, elevator type of thing. And then they take me and they put me in this cell. And the cells there are these little boxes really. And there's a metal bed, with some sort of mat. And a toilet without a toilet seat, and that's it. There's nothing else in there. And I'm in there by myself.
他们把我带到一栋楼，原来在环线（Loop）区。他们把我带出来，穿过地下室，乘自动扶梯还是电梯之类的东西上去。然后他们把我关进一间牢房。那里的牢房确实就是些小盒子。有一个金属床，上面有块垫子。还有一个没有座圈的马桶，除此之外什么都没有。我独自一人呆在里面。
Again I ask what I've been arrested for, and again they say, we don't know. I ask for my phone call, and they say you can make your phone call in a certain period of time. They leave me in there for a little while. And I'm sitting on the bed and the man in the cell next to me begins to shout and scream. And he sounds loud and big. He sounds like a big man. And no one comes when he shouts and screams. And he's screaming for the for the jailer to come, he wants him to come.
我再次问我因为什么被捕，他们依然说不知道。我要求打个电话，他们说你过一会儿可以打。他们把我留在里面待了一会儿。我坐在床上，隔壁牢房的男人开始大喊大叫。他声音听起来很响亮。他听起来像个大块头。他喊叫时没人理会。他尖叫着让狱警过来。
And so he starts to pound with both fists on the wall, that is my wall and his wall are the same wall. And it's like a drum, so there's this very big [POUNDING NOISES] sound going with it. And this screaming. This goes on for really a long time. Like, literally hours. And every once in a while, somebody comes in and yells at him. And he stops for a couple of beats, and then he continues.
于是他开始用双拳猛击墙壁，那是我的墙也是他的墙，是同一面墙。它就像一面鼓，发出非常大的[重击声]，伴随着尖叫。这持续了很长时间。字面意思上的好几个小时。每过一会儿，有人进来对他大喊。他停顿两下，然后继续。
And so I can't sleep, even if I want to sleep. And then the cell opens, and this young man comes in. And he's a newly arrested prisoner as well, as he quickly tells me. And he's already pretty high, which I know. I can tell that. And he tells me quickly, too. So we have a little discussion about what it's like to be high. And he sits down, and he says, "Well, do you want to do some? Because I got to do this before the morning." And I said, "Do some? No No, I don't want to."
所以我睡不着，就算我想睡也不行。然后牢房开了，一个年轻人进来了。他也是个刚被捕的囚犯，他很快告诉我。我知道他已经神志恍惚了。看得出来。他也很快告诉我了。所以我们讨论了一下嗑药的感觉。他坐下来，说：“你想来点吗？因为我得在早上前用掉。”我说：“来点？不，不，我不要。”
And he takes this aluminum foil-- it's dope. I'm not sure what it is. I figured it was smack because of the way he acted. But I wasn't sure. And he has it up his ass. And he literally leans over and he pulls it out of his ass. And then he unwraps it and he takes it. And he very quickly gets really, really stoned. And very loquacious. And so he's talking, he's telling me mostly about the day, and the neighborhood and where he lives and what he can get and what he can't get when he's on the street. And what job he could get if he could just get over there and do it. He is mostly just rambling through.
他拿出锡纸——那是毒品。我不确定是什么。因为他的行为，我觉得那是海洛因（smack）。但我不敢肯定。他把它藏在屁股里。他真的俯下身，把它从屁股里掏出来。然后打开包装用了起来。他很快变得非常、非常飘。而且话很多。他基本上是在告诉我这一天，邻里，他住的地方，他在街上能弄到什么不能弄到什么。如果他能振作起来去干活，他能找什么工作。他大部分时间只是在胡言乱语。
And after the first, you know, 15 minutes of it, I'm done talking to him. So I pretend to sleep. And I lie on the top of the bed with my eyes closed, but he keeps talking. And periodically the man, who has stopped slamming, begins to slam again on the wall next to us. So that's the first night.
在最初的15分钟对话后，我不想再跟他聊了。所以我假装睡觉。我躺在床上闭着眼睛，但他一直没完没了。隔壁那个男人停止撞击后又开始猛撞墙壁。这就是第一晚。
In the morning, a new jailer comes and says now I can make the phone call. So I go and I make the phone call and I reach a family member who says they'll reach somebody else who will reach a lawyer. That's all I know. And again, still, no one has given me an answer to what I had been arrested for.
早晨，一个新狱警过来，说我现在可以打电话了。我去打了电话，联系上了一位家庭成员，他说会联系某人再联系律师。我只知道这些。而且，依然没有人给我答案说明我因为什么被捕。
The second night, I think the second night-- and this seems like the middle of the night, it seems like midnight, one o'clock in the morning, I really don't know what time is, they come and they got me. And they say, you have a visitor. And they take me to one of those rooms that you see in the prison movies where there's a glass thing and you to speak through a grate, and there's a little microphone that barely works. And there's things written on the inside the Plexiglas and scratched with pens or something.
第二天晚上，我想应该是第二天晚上——好像是半夜，午夜一点，我真的不知道是什么时间，他们来带走我。他们说，你有访客。他们带我到一个你在监狱电影里看到的房间，那里有个玻璃窗，必须通过格栅说话，有个几乎坏掉的小麦克风。有机玻璃内侧写着东西，或者用笔划过什么的。
And my sister-- one of my sisters-- is there. And she has this whole sheath of papers. So she holds up these papers so that I can see them, and it's from the state of Wisconsin. And my daughter's name is on the piece of paper. I have a daughter. This case is about my daughter. The state of Wisconsin is suing me for back child support. 17 years before. I think it's about $14,000 or something at this point.
我的姐姐——我的一个姐姐——在那儿。她拿着一大叠纸。她举起这些纸让我看，是威斯康星州发出的。纸上写着我女儿的名字。我有个女儿。这案子和我女儿有关。威斯康星州正在起诉我要求补缴17年前的子女抚养费。我想这大概有14000美元什么的。
And I see the paper, and I'm very surprised by it, because the history of it is that I lived with this woman, and we had a child. And we didn't have jobs. And if you are on welfare and food stamps and you're unmarried, the state of Wisconsin will bill the father in the form of child support. So when my daughter was three years old and she was living with me, I was called in to court. And I went in front of the judge, and I said, "I don't think I should have to be paying this money, because I am raising my child, and I'm paying for her care." And the judge said, "You're right. get out of here."
看到这文件我很惊讶，因为事情的经过是我和这个女人住在一起，我们有个孩子。我们没有工作。如果你领着救济金和食品券，而且未婚，威斯康星州会以子女抚养费的名义向父亲索要。所以我女儿三岁时她和我住在一起，我被叫去法庭。我在法官面前说：“我不认为我该付这笔钱，因为我在养我的孩子，我在支付她的抚养费。”法官说：“你是对的。滚吧。”
And I assumed, at that point, that had been stricken from the books. And I just walked out of the courtroom that day, I didn't pay any money, I didn't get arrested. I took the bus home. And I guess that that never got written down, there was some clerical error about it, because it was never changed in the system. The state of Wisconsin still thought I owed them this money, plus interest. And I never heard from them again until now.
当时我以为这件事已经从账目上划掉了。那天我走出法庭，没付钱，也没被捕。我坐公交回了家。我想那件事从来没记录下来，系统里有些笔误，因为系统里从来没改过。威斯康星州依然认为我欠他们钱，连同利息。在此之前我再也没收到过他们的消息。
And so this is 17 years later that this is now happening, from that court appearance. I'm sitting in the cell and my own past is catching up to me. Within a year of me going in front of the judge in Wisconsin, my daughter's mother really shifts direction, and she starts religion hopping is what I used to call it. Where she moves from one religion to another and she moves around a lot during this time. She keeps leaving, coming back and leaving and coming back.
17年后，这件事才从那次法庭出庭中发生。我坐在牢房里，我自己的过去追上了我。我出庭威斯康星那年之后不到一年，我女儿的母亲就彻底改变了方向，她开始“玩宗教跳跃”，我以前是这么叫它的。她从一个宗教换到另一个，期间搬来搬去。
And in the course of that year, I also start going the opposite direction. Smoking a lot more pot than I had before, and drinking heavily. And one day I come home and my daughter's mother has taken my daughter. And left.
那一年里，我也开始走向相反的方向。比以前抽更多大麻，酗酒严重。有一天我回家，发现我女儿的母亲带走了我的女儿，离开了。
And at first I thought that that would change pretty quickly. I expected to hear from them over the next period of months. I didn't. I went further and further into lots of dope and lots of alcohol, and it wasn't until years later, after I had long stopped drinking and smoking pot, that I was able to really look at my own responsibility for it. That I had messed up. That I was responsible for someone and I didn't take care of her.
起初我以为这种情况很快会改变。我本以为接下来的几个月会收到她们的消息。但我没有。我陷得越来越深，沉溺于毒品和酒精中，直到多年后，在戒除酒瘾和大麻很久之后，我才能够真正直面自己的责任。我搞砸了。我本该对一个人负责，但我没照顾好她。
I didn't see here. I didn't help wit money. And then it was a long time, 12 years, which is impossible to ever make that right. Just too long. And finally my daughter contacted me when she was 14 or 15, and I saw how much I'd hurt her. There was no pretense about it. There's no "I'm sorry, let's make it right," because there's something that's completely been lost and broken. And the kid had no say about it.
我没见她。我没提供过金钱帮助。后来过了很久，12年，这辈子都弥补不回来了。时间太长了。直到我女儿14或15岁时联系了我，我才看到我伤害她有多深。那没有任何借口。没有“对不起，让我弥补”之类的，因为有些东西已经彻底破碎遗失了。而这孩子对此根本没得选。
And that begins a series of contacts then between my daughter and I. And it's often uncomfortable. She's a teenage girl, a suburban teenage girl. We don't know each other. It can be hard to find things to talk about. And as time goes on over this, I call her, she doesn't call me back. She calls me, I don't call her back right away. Things get put off. And there's still a lot of distance in the relationship.
这开启了之后我和女儿之间的一系列联络。这通常很尴尬。她是个青少年女孩，郊区青少年女孩。我们彼此不了解。很难找到共同话题。随着时间的推移，我打电话给她，她不回。她打电话给我，我没及时回。事情被推迟。关系中依然有很多距离。
That next morning, they bring me and what seems like probably about 60 other guys and they take us to now the big courthouse where we're all going to be tried. And there they bring you-- I think it's like four cells. So there's maybe 300 guys in these four cells. And I'm sitting on this bench, and these three older men come in. And everybody seems to know them, and they sort of spread out and give them the space. And they sit on this central bench. And one of them takes out a joint and lights it. And they pass this joint back and forth, and they sit there and smoke it. And nobody says anything. They just smoke this joint.
第二天早晨，他们带上我和大概60个其他家伙，把我们带到大法院，我们要在那儿受审。他们把我们带进……我想大概是四个牢房。这四个牢房里大概有300个人。我坐在长凳上，三个老人走了进来。每个人似乎都认识他们，他们散开并为他们腾出空间。他们坐在中间的长凳上。其中一个掏出一根大麻烟点燃。他们传递着抽，坐在那儿抽。没人说什么。他们只是抽着烟。
Then these two young men come up to where I'm sitting, and one of them says, "Give us some money. Give us your money. We want to get some. Give us your money." And I said, "Well, no. I'm not going to give you my money." And they said, "Well, you have some money in that jacket, right?" I say, "Yeah, actually I do. But it's my money. I'm going to probably need it." I'm keeping this, again, this quietness of tone, but, again, not looking him right in the eye. And he's like, "No, man, I'm telling you. Give me the money." And I say, "Well, I'm not going to."
然后两个年轻人走到我坐的地方，其中一个说：“给我们点钱。把钱交出来。我们要买点货。交出你的钱。”我说：“嗯，不。我不会给你们我的钱。”他们说：“好吧，你有钱在那夹克里，对吧？”我说：“是的，确实有。但那是我的钱。我可能需要它。”我依然保持这种平和的语调，但没直视他的眼睛。他就像：“不，哥们，我告诉你。把钱给我。”我说：“不，我不会给的。”
So then a third guy comes, and the three of them are standing around me in the circle. And the first young man is doing most of the speaking. And he's insisting, "I'm going to take your jacket. I want your money." And then, across the way, one of the older man says "Hey. Pops. Pops." And I look up, and he's looking at me. And he says, "It's Pops, right?" And I say, "Yeah, yeah. Pops." And he says, "Yeah, that's just Pops. Leave him alone."
于是第三个家伙来了，三个人围成一圈站在我身边。第一个年轻人说了大部分话。他坚持说：“我要拿走你的夹克。我要你的钱。”就在这时，对面一个老人说：“嘿，老爹。老爹。”我抬头，他看着我。他说：“是叫老爹吧？”我说：“是的，是的，老爹。”他说：“行了，那是老爹。别管他。”
And the three young men sort of move away, and the guy says again, "Pops, you want some of this?" Some of this being the dope. To smoke. And I say, "No, no thank you."
那三个年轻人走开了，那家伙又说：“老爹，想来点吗？”指的就是毒品。可以抽。我说：“不，不用了，谢谢。”
And here I am, I'm in jail because of what I did, you know, 20 years ago and the year I was living 20 years ago. And I'm surrounded by these guys that I really recognize from that way of living. I was proud of that, I lived like them too. This is who I was, when I lost my daughter.
我在这里，是因为我20年前所做的事，因为20年前那一年里我的生活。我被那些我确实认出来的家伙包围着，那正是那种生活方式的人。我曾经以此为荣，我也像他们一样生活。这就是我失去女儿时的样子。
So I get taken into the courtroom and my lawyer says, "I think we can get you off. We certainly can get this reduced. You don't have to pay all of this money. So what is it that you want to do?" And I thought about it. And I said, "No, I think I know what I want to do. Which is that I want to make this right today. I want to pay this money." And the lawyer said, "No, come on, you don't have to do that. It's too much money. We can get you off of this."
我被带进法庭，我的律师说：“我想我能让你脱身。我们肯定能减轻判决。你不需要支付全部钱。你想怎么做？”我考虑了一下。我说：“不，我想我知道我想怎么做。我今天想把这事办妥。我想付这笔钱。”律师说：“不，得了吧，你不需要这么做。钱太多了。我们可以帮你脱身。”
And I thought about it. And it wasn't that I felt that by paying the money I would be then closer to my daughter. It wasn't that. It was, I'm wanting at this point, to make amends to my daughter in any way possible. Whatever is going to make her life easier, whatever I can do for her, now I'll do. I'm actually grateful for it, because it gives me a means. It give me a way, it gives me a clear, simple way.
我考虑了一下。并非我觉得付了钱就能离我女儿更近。并不是这样。是我在这一点上，想以任何可能的方式补偿我的女儿。任何能让她的生活变轻松的事，任何我能为她做的，我现在都会做。我其实很感激这件事，因为它给了我一种手段。它给了我一条明确、简单的途径。
So a deal is struck, right there in front of the judge, where if I can come up with a portion of the money right then, they'll release me and set up a monthly payment plan where I get to pay off the rest of it. And I do that. And I don't know if my daughter even knows that the money came from me. But I know that the money went to her.
所以就在法官面前达成了协议，如果我能立刻筹集一部分钱，他们就会释放我，并设定每月还款计划来付清余下的部分。我照办了。我不知道我女儿是否知道钱是我出的。但我知道钱确实汇给了她。
Something then really did change between us. And what changed was me. I could talk to her more easily. I could show her the way I felt about her more easily. And because I responded with ease, she responded to that over time. She was then more easy with me. She was more able to just be easy with me. And when she really gets into difficulty, and has trouble, a few years later, she's able to reach out to me. And I'm able to reach back.
此后我们的关系确实发生了改变。改变的是我。我能更容易地跟她交谈了。我能更容易地向她表达我对她的感受。因为我回应得很从容，久而久之她也对此做出了回应。她对我来说更容易交流了。她能够更容易地与我相处。当几年后她真正遇到困难时，她能够联系我。而我也能伸出援手。
So this weird trip into the underworld has really actually been this weird gift to me. If it took being dragged off a plane, and handcuffed and held in a jail cell and being around people pulling heroin out of their asses and going to court. If it took all that to bring about some sort of resolution of something between me and my daughter, then it was worth it.
所以这趟诡异的“地下世界”之旅，实际上成了我的意外收获。如果代价是被拖下飞机，戴上手铐，关进牢房，和那些把海洛因从屁股里掏出来的人待在一起，还要去法庭。如果所有这些是为了我和我女儿之间某些问题的化解，那么这一切都是值得的。
Playwrite and actor Beau O'Reilly. He is performing as the Lord of the Underworld in Euridice at the Victory Gardens Theater in Chicago. It opens  the first week of October.
剧作家兼演员博·奥赖利。他将在芝加哥胜利花园剧院（Victory Gardens Theater）出演《欧律狄刻》（Euridice）中的“地下世界之主”。该剧将于10月第一周首演。
I carried the child on my own back from the border while escaping from Dombrowa to Miejov.
我背着孩子从边境逃离，从栋布罗瓦逃到梅约夫。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week, with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。
Next week, her on the podcast of This American Life.
下周，在《美国生活》播客上。
Saving 500, 1,000 kids, 1,500 kids simply was not going to make a difference. We had to really think big.
拯救500个、1000个、1500个孩子根本不会有什么改变。我们必须真正想得宏大。
Life inside a radical new experiment to eliminate urban poverty, that draws on new research about how kids develop and is implemented on a scale unlike any program ever undertaken, anywhere in this country. That's next week on your local public radio station and here on the podcast.
这是一个消除城市贫困的激进新实验，它基于关于儿童如何成长的新研究，并以前所未有的规模在本国任何地方实施。下周请收听当地公共广播电台及本播客。